[Music]
[Applause]
on this Friday night Israel bombs a
convoy of ambulances in
Gaza why Israel says it carried out the
deadly attack and the refusal to pause
the fighting plus the new hope of
getting fuel into Gaza the guilt of not
being in Gaza we W buy our family as
those stuck there grow desperate to get
out and Chaos from Kieran how this
brutal storm is both a super soer and a
fire
starter global national with forign
Asser good evening we begin with
breaking news tonight Global News has
confirmed that Canadians stuck in Gaza
could leave as early as Sunday while
civilian casualties there keep climbing
every day Israel is claiming
responsibility for an air strike on an
ambulance Convoy out outside gaza's
largest hospital and a warning some of
these images are
disturbing Israel says the Convoy was
transporting Hamas Fighters gaza's Hamas
run Health Ministry says it was
transporting critically wounded patients
from alifa hospital to the Rafa border
crossing according to that Health
Ministry more than 9,000 people in Gaza
have been killed by Israeli air strikes
since October the 7th Israel says that
on that day Hamas attacked and killed
more than 1,400 people in southern
Israel the IDF says at least 23 Israeli
soldiers have
died today prime minister Justin Trudeau
reiterated calls for a break in fighting
so that Aid can get in and that people
can get out when that happens the
Egyptian government says those leaving
Gaza through the Raffa border crossing
will be allowed to stay in Egypt for 3
days we need a humanitarian pause all
the hostages
need to be
released we need much more Aid going to
the Palestinian people and we need
innocent civilians to be
protected the US is echoing this it's a
subtle shift in tone in America's
unequivocal support for Israel in his
third face to face since Israel's war on
Hamas began US Secretary of State
Anthony blinkin pushed Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu today for
humanitarian pause something net Yahoo
pushed back on Mike Armstrong on the
shifting us strategy and the real life
consequences of Israel's actions in
Gaza the lines in Gaza start at first
light families queuing up for things
like water or bread but even in the
desperation the bigger concern is the
fighting we don't want food says Hussein
alady we want to cease fire that's
all now the US is making a similar call
in person The American Secretary of
State touchdown in Tel Aviv Friday
meeting the Israeli Prime Minister and
the country's War cabinet Anthony
blinkin pushed Israeli leaders to hold
humanitarian pauses in the fighting it
would allow Aid to get to Gaz and
civilians he says and make it easier to
get the hostages held by Hamas back we
believe that a humanitarian pause could
uh help that
effort well the appeal for restraint was
rejected basically as soon as blinkin
left the country Benjamin Netanyahu says
there will be no ceasefire until the
hostages are freed Israel he said will
continue bombarding Gaza with quote all
of its
power fuel is essential now un officials
say there may be progress on getting
fuel into Gaza negotiations are underway
to move diesel into the strip to help
keep generators running at hospitals and
to help with the distribution of water
but the UN also says 72 of its staff
members have been killed in Gaza and the
rest are struggling to do their jobs not
enough Aid is being allowed in we are
effectively starved of the vital
humanitarian supplies that we need uh to
provide to
people the conditions are also difficult
for those sharing stories from Gaza
journalists in the strip buried a
colleague
Friday this is Palestinian journalist
Muhammad Abu hatab reporting Thursday he
was later killed in an explosion at his
home his colleagues found out he was
dead while live on air an independent
NGO that promotes press Freedom says
since October 7th 36 journalists and
media workers have been
killed
now the cost of helping people in this
conflict is rising on October 12th the
UN said it would need about 300 million
us to support 1.3 million people in Gaza
and the West Bank through the end of the
year it now says it will have to help
more than twice as many people 2.7
million and it will cost $1.2 billion
for times as much
far Mike Armstrong in Jerusalem thank
you Israel's also on high alert along
its northern border after hezbollah's
leader threatened to escalate attacks
today in his first speech since the
conflict erupted Hassan nasala praised
Hamas for its attack on October 7th and
warned the world that fighting between
iran-backed militants and Israeli troops
on the Lebanese front could spill over
saying quote a total war is realistic
unless Israel halts its assault on Gaza
Israel's retaliation on Hamas has not
only decimated lives in Gaza it's also
affected those gazin trying to make a
living outside of it today thousands of
Palestinians who worked in Israel and in
the occupied West Bank returned to Gaza
they were detained after the events of
October 7th some say they were
mistreated by Israeli authorities many
had ID number tags attached to their leg
and claim they were beaten Palestinian
workers can make 10 times more money in
Israel than in Gaza around 18,000 people
had permits to do so Danielle hjin has a
story of two fathers whose families have
been ripped apart by this
conflict everybody here is glued to a
phone for updates from Gaza which
building was bombed did the children
have something to eat today did the
Neighbors
[Music]
survive
is where they wish they
were there are construction workers
farmers and waiters who live in The
Enclave but work throughout Israel to
earn more money their permits were
suspended on October 7th leaving them
with nowhere else to
go but 80 kilomet away in a sports
complex in the West Bank where many are
consumed by the guilt of not suffering
alongside their wives and children my
wife my wife at this
time she is the the dad and the mother
and
every every person for our
children because we because I'm
here but my heart is in
Gaza Tamir studied civil engineering but
made a living waiting tables in Northern
Israel we are
die
we don't want food we don't want water
we want my our
family every night we all all cry all
worker cry yeah please visit visit us in
the night
today so you you you see everyone cry
with his
family he keeps promising his children
he'll take them to a restaurant but all
they want they tell him is a hug from
their dad this is my
family T the big daughter and Lana and
the little one is Ahmed my son my
heart this
is and this is my daughter of
fre and as the Sun starts to set in Tel
Aviv she just turned 10 and another
father is about to spend another night
without his children and his wife
weekend we said I don't believe that
they're evil over there I think they
want to live their lives just like I
want to live my life and conflicts are
things that happen so I have no sense of
Vengeance Revenge nothing at all I just
want my family back and I really wish
for them to be United with their
families as
well every day avihai Bret stands
outside the Israeli Ministry of Defense
in protest and in
desperation his entire family is
believed to be held hostage by
I miss the mess they make you know after
they come back home from
school and I miss making them
dinner and I miss the mess they make
after eating dinner and I miss Yuval
playing his
Xbox miss them ruining my garden
outside I miss my
wife I don't like sleeping
alone you know I miss brushing my teeth
with my wife
broet a nursing student is not
particularly religious and never
supported any of the wars nearly a month
after they were taken he's not sure how
to keep hope he'll ever see his family
again Danielle Hamin Global News
Jerusalem as we mentioned some of the
more than 500 Canadians in Gaza will be
allowed to leave as early as Sunday it
has been weeks of uncertainty
desperation and frustration for their
family members here ncha reports they
don't deserve to die as a collateral
damage Omar Mansour is thankful his
parents brother and six sisters are
alive in Gaza but he worries every
moment of every day that could change
they went out of all kind of water um
any uh medical supplies or um Food
Supplies the Canadian permanent resident
says this was the apartment where one of
his sisters her husband and their two
kids move moved to in southern Gaza they
came here a few days into the conflict
as Israel ordered people to move South
manour says the day they got here they
survived an air strike which destroyed
the neighborhood we've seen more
bleeding coming through their nose
because of all the chemicals of the
bombings that is around them since
October 7th Mansour says he has gone
days without being able to reach his
relatives on Wednesday he contacted his
sister Ruba in southern Gaza shortly
after an air strike
nearby we are under Fire all time
despite the spotty connection we were
able to speak with mansour's Uncle who's
an American citizen he says he and his
immediate family have traveled to Rafa
Crossing twice this week after after
getting conflicting information from the
American Embassy in Jerusalem no one's
pushing for us to evacuate or to leave
Gaza as American
citizen I need to know what's going on
mansur's immediate family are gazin he
said he came to Canada nearly a decade
ago in hopes of helping them I witnessed
the 56 days war in 2014 which afterwards
I decided to come and move to Canada for
Education this is how skinny I was
because there was no food for like 20
days and while he's now a world away he
has an idea of what they're going
through when genocide happens people
understand that it's a genocide when
it's too
late it's not too late to stop a
genocide you need to act right now Nea
Global News
Vancouver while International attention
has been focused in the Middle East
Russia launched a sprawling attack
across Ukraine overnight marking one of
the most extensive rounds of shelling in
the war so far this
year firefighters work to tame massive
fires in Ukraine's second largest city
of harke one of the hardest hit in the
overnight attacks drones are said to
have struck residential buildings in key
infrastructure according to keev
Ukrainian military officials say Russia
has shelled nearly 120 cities and
villages in the past 24 hours the number
of casualties in the attack is still
unclear Canada's defense minister is
condemning what he calls unprofessional
and unsafe acts by a Chinese war plane
after it fired flares in front of a
Canadian helicopter over international
waters last weekend the helicopter pilot
had to maneuver to avoid the flares and
reduce the risk of injesting ingesting a
flare into the helicopter's rotor and
intakes these Maneuvers put the safety
of all Personnel involved in unnecessary
risk Bill Blair says the intercepts took
place over the South China Sea while
Canadian Crews were conducting routine
exercises he's raised concerns with
Beijing China has drawn criticism not
only from Canada but the US EU and Japan
among others for similar incidents in
the
past in Ottawa Finance Minister Christa
Freeland spoke with her provincial and
territorial counterparts today about
Alberta's plan to exit the Canadian
pension plan Freeland once again warned
about the potential consequences and
complications if Alberta follows through
with the idea and as Mackenzie gray
reports the federal government seeking
more clarity over how much money Alberta
is entitled to it's utta was response to
a potential pension split this has never
happened before that's why it's going to
be really really important to have a
calm fact-based
conversation at the core of that
conversation how much the Alberta
Government could get from the Canada
Pension Plan if it follows through and
its pitch to start its own retirement
fund a report commissioned by Premier
Daniel Smith says Alberta could get over
330 billion but that figure is in
dispute do you think that is a realistic
number that the pension plan could
potentially have to give to a bur as
they left no I do not to give a federal
dollar figure Finance Minister chrisa
Freeland announcing the chief Federal
actuary will review the pension
legislation which does allow any
Province to leave the fund the Alberta
Finance Minister promising that will
only happen if Alberton vote to do so in
a referendum but the terms of a vote and
numerous other issues like pension
portability concerning Alberta
businesses we can't risk that as a
country we need to be able to be
competitive and uncertainty does not
keep us competitive you are better off
sharing risk with a bigger pool of
capital than trying to go it alone but
it's not just business groups in the
federal government even conservative
leader Pierre pev and NDP Premier don't
want Alberta to leave the CPP we believe
it's a good system we think it effective
for British Colombians and for Canadians
as as a whole the other topic discussed
at the virtual meeting the carbon tax
with a number of provinces asking for
additional car votes for different types
of home heating fuel but Christa
Freeland says that topic will be
discussed in December far the next time
the finance ministers are scheduled to
meet okay Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank
you McKenzie as Canada's unemployment
rate Rises find out what the world's
richest man thinks is going to happen
with the rise of AI that's coming
up
for the fourth time in six months
Canada's unemployment rate Rose as high
interest rates increasingly weigh on the
economy data from statistics Canada
shows unemployment ticked up to 5.7% in
October that's a 2% increase over the
previous month and it translat to more
than 1.2 million unemployed people
across the country the softening job
market has many economists predicting
the Bank of Canada will likely continue
a pause in raising its key lending rate
which sits at 5
5% controversial billionaire Elon Musk
believes those job numbers won't matter
in the near future as the use of
artificial intelligence Rises speaking
to British prime minister Rishi sunak
musk described the technology as the
most disruptive force in history you can
have a job if you want to have a job for
sort of personal satisfaction but the AI
will be able to do everything have three
limits limits musk was attending the
first AI safety Summit hosted by the UK
a at managing the risks of Technology
International leaders like the US vice
president the European Union president
and the UN Secretary General also took
part leading tech companies including
Microsoft and meta were also
present record-breaking rainfall ahead
the muddy mess left behind in Italy by
storm
[Music]
Kieran at least six people have been
killed in Italy's Tuscany region after
record-breaking rainfall caused several
rivers to burst their
Banks rescue workers paddled through
flooded streets after storm Kieran hit
the area overnight it dumped nearly 200
millimeters of rainfall in a 3-hour
period forcing nearly 200 people out of
their homes the storm first swept across
parts of Western Europe Thursday killing
seven people
there wind from the storm is also
believed to have fueled this wildfire in
eastern Spain some 2,000 hectares of
land has been burned and at least 850
people have been forced out of their
homes the area is now bracing for
incoming storm Domingos which is
expected to make landfall on
Saturday the push to produce renewable
energy why a government decision could
spell trouble for Alberta's efforts to
go
green if Canada hopes to reach its
climate goals in the coming years
renewable energy will need to play a
major role wind and solar have become
cost- effective and reliable sources of
power and for the better part of the
last decade Alberta has led the way
Heather Yorks West on a government
decision that's putting it all at risk
Heather known for its Rich oil and gas
resources Alberta has been quietly
fostering a renewable energy boom that
is until its government announced a
six-month pause in development earlier
this year but the players involved in
this boom may surprise you this massive
wind farm near Medicine Hat was
developed by the oil sands giant suncore
before being acquired by Atco a company
synonymous with natural gas yeah we're
pretty consistent with the schedule we
laid out located minutes from downtown
Calgary ato's newest solar project is
almost ready to be electrified the twin
sites at Deerfoot and Barlo set to
produce enough power to light up 18,000
homes are part of the company's rapidly
expanding renewable energy portfolio
over the course of time it'll be a
multi-billion dollar investment uh here
in the province and in Canada and Atco
is not alone in fact over the last
decade Alberta has seen a renewable
energy boom we have some of the best
wind and also some of the best sun in
parts of the The Province and then also
that competitive market that competitive
market unlike any other place in Canada
me investors could come in set up
projects and sell electricity into the
grid but then this past August Alberta's
government hit the brakes if we're going
to bring on solar and wind we have to do
it responsibly citing concerns with grid
stability and whether projects were
taking over too much of Alberta's
agricultural lands The Province
announced no new projects would be
approved for 6 months taking the
industry completely by surprise and
introducing Market uncertainty so even
if we get through this period now the
question becomes you know what might
this government do in the future around
renewable energy there is much more to
this story than meets the eye and even
then the path forward is anything but
clear far Heather Eric West in 40 mile
County Alberta thanks
Heather and you can watch Heather's full
story on Alberta's renewable energy boom
and bust tomorrow night at 7 on the new
reality right here on global and that is
global national for this Friday night
I'm faren Asser and on behalf of our
whole crew here I want to thank you so
much for spending part of your evening
with us tonight's your Canada is
majestic kroer Bay in Lancaster sound
Nuno we love seeing your Canada so
please keep emailing us your photos to
viewers at Global national.com until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
take care of each other good
[Music]
night